[Musique]
bruay en artois 4 heures du matin
à la cité 14 rue de la conté il y à de
la lumière
c'est gisèle flahaut la mère de famille
qui est déjà levé
[Musique]
manger maintenant il doit être quatre
heures et demie puisque madame flahaut
vient d'appeler roger
roger à 15 il travaille au fond depuis 2
illégal ebooks alors terme entre deux
bonnes heures à midi on va tous
aujourd'hui et samedi he puis corrado
référendum enfin vers 1 heure à une
heure et demie seraient l'autre
roger ne sera pas de retour avant 13h40
à 5h un autre fils flahaut henry à se
lève à son tour il a 18 ans lui aussi
travaille au fond je veux dire aux
produits donnent à manger aux pigeons
tout leur est permis d'y lever bio
jamais de faire une machine surveillé
alors qu'au mieux en matière il s'agit
d'un devoir essayer de venir en face des
flahaut au 25 de la rue de la comté
habitent les delmotte madame delmotte et
l'ami de madame flahaut henry delmotte
travaille dans la même taille qu'henri
flahaut aussi h 15
d'ailleurs tous les hommes de la cité
travail au siège 4 ils se relaient au
fond de 8 heures en huit
quand on quitte le jour comme des
mineurs on passe ici ou lavabo avant de
descendre
[Musique]
comme henri flahaut on laisse là tous
ses vêtements tous ses effets personnels
pour revêtir la tenue uniforme du mineur
on devient un autre homme
à la lampisterie envie va prendre sa
lampe et sa payet
il a touché sa payet numéro 2658 henry
delmotte lui est devenu le numéro 1174
[Musique]
celui qui commande la manoeuvre de la
cage c'est l'oncle env l'oncle de
reflets et d'henri flahaut
[Musique]
il expédie la cage à 706 m de fond à une
vitesse de 11 mètres seconde
voilà le père de famille il s'appelle
edward flahaut au meilleur il n'était
pas trop bien et puis quand même
d'essayer m'attend fourchette bras c'est
le métier de mineur chez duras le métier
de mineur ouais ouais
puis il faut espérer que le petit jean
pierre qui n'ira pas nos pu reposer ses
abords tâcher d'y trouver un autre
emploi kyo à c'est lui jean-pierre la
cinquième enfant
et voici nelly la petite fille l'aînée
maurice descente au fond depuis sept ans
mais cette semaine il est de l'après
midi il en profite pour dormir un
edouard flahaut lui et du matin cette
semaine
il est machiniste d'extraction comme son
frère l'oncle ans mais lui est
titularisé et son frère ne l'est pas
ainsi les deux frères se relaient aux
manettes qui actionne la carte 700
mètres plus bas
roger et henri travail
[Musique]
projet à bon port
[Applaudissements]
l'ami delmotte et abattent
le travail de huit heures par jour une
seule interruption à 10h pour le briquet
c'est à dire le casse-croûte delmotte et
henri flahaut s'y retrouve et de quoi
parle-t-il sinon de pigeons obligé pour
vous l'avez flotter au coeur du rideau
voilà un matin d'hiver dont on est fier
d'y avoir séduit les mam est en
profondeur où trouver les bons celui-ci
est pour nous mais les conseils bon ne
nous donne pas les jouer ses métiers
grâce aux liens qu'il aurait les gens
mais quand il faut de m'avoir l'habitat
est épaulé aussi des données
la poussière de charbon donne
quelquefois au gast route un goût amer
le charbon est partout à vaulruz et même
à la surface il flotte dans l'air il se
dépose dans les jardins et sur les
maisons les femmes du nord tiennent
beaucoup à la propreté de leur maison
mais elles ont vraiment beaucoup de
travail autour du siège sis elles ont
renoncé à faire leur lessive en semaine
le linge et noir en moins d'une on peut
laver que le dimanche
les jardins aussi sont recouverts d'une
épaisse poussière noire il faudra c'est
la salade dans cinq hausses successives
avant que l'eau de rinçage soient
claires
le charbon c'est à la fois la richesse
du pays et son malheur quand il se
dépose dans les poumons il donne lieu à
une maladie qu'on appelle la silicose
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
13 les mineurs qui étaient du matin
remontent à la surface
leur premier souci est de se laver de
retrouver l'homme qu'ils étaient avec
son visage sa personnalité
[Musique]
ranger flahaut redevient lui même avant
de regagner le jour
madame flahaut ne l'a pas attendu pour
se mettre à table
car son fils maurice doit descendre au
fond à 2h15 il va reléguer son frère
henry et son ami delmotte
bah ouais la feuillure avion et ce
qu'est un éboulement père blessé et
blessé gtoi l'installeur une bouteille
pour ip man et puis mon mac
du coup de pression pour les mouvements
et à laisser saint pierre de bouteilles
et en sont alors on aura beau temps et a
reculé de l'année puis à quoi c'est
simple soit casse inquiète ou que tout
fracturé combien voyez tout écraser
peut-être obligé de couper
13h25 delmotte remontent à la surface
[Musique]
roger flahaut lui ne rentrera cas 13h40
pour lui madame flahaut devra faire un
deuxième service de déjeuner à 2h15 en
rire entre à son tour
oui j'ai vu
henry n'est pas pressé des jeunes et la
première chose qu'il fait c'est d'aller
donner à manger à ses piges bien il les
connaît tous par leur nom et ses pigeons
n'accepte de gracq de lui seul manawi là
on devra faire un vrai défi ainsi le
fourneau reste toujours allumés du matin
au soir chez les flahaut et il consomme
beaucoup de charbon
ce sont les houillères qui distribue à
chaque foyer une ration régulière de
bois et charbon
tout ce qu'on possède bien des
houillères
la rue appartient ou hier la maison
appartient ou hier le jardin appartient
aux moulières les deux arts de champ que
cultivent les flahaut appartient de
houillères changer de métier
signifierait pour les flahaut renoncer à
leur logement et à leur jardin quitter
leurs quartiers leurs amis
on comprend qu'ils y regardent à deux
fois
paris lé 185 22e nom maurice travail en
équipe avec kosmala qui est délégué
syndicat chaque mineur et payé en
fonction de la tâche accomplie
c'est le pognon qui décide du salaire
qui sera due à chacun à la fin de la
case états volent tu veux te faire plus
petit que je dois je ne me rappelle pas
la goldwing le 10 et le 25 de chaque
mois son jour de paye beaucoup de femmes
de mineurs se rendre au siège 4 ces
jours là pour toucher les paies de la
famille
les femmes ne sont pas dépaysés à la
mine car elles ont travaillé là
autrefois comme trier c'est là qu'elle
doit flower rencontré gisèle pour la
première fois
le
les mineurs travaillent 48 heures par
semaine le salaire moyen pour le bassin
du nord et du pas-de-calais et de 50 de
1800 francs par mois en déduisant les
charges sociales on arrive à 48 mille
francs nets mais c'est une moyenne
générale des galibots comme roger ou
comme henry sont loin d'atteindre de
telles sommes par contre un abatteur
comme delmotte peut gagner entre 56
milles et 69 mille francs par mois de
salaires effectifs nets les jours de
paye des marchands ambulants installent
leurs tréteaux à la sortie de la mine
les mineurs qui se sont privés depuis
plusieurs jours dans la tente du salaire
sont très tentés de dépenser leur argent
ces jours là c'est peut-être pour cette
raison que beaucoup de femmes vont
chercher elle-même la paix
la femme gère le budget du foyer c'est
sa fonction revenus c'est elle qui
répartit à chacun son argent de poche
pour sa quinzaine roger touche 500
francs enrichissant maurice mille leur
père 15 sans frêche
casanova je ne crois pas qu'un à maurice
affichée avec chalon corps avec un jour
faire attention et chacun utilise son
argent de poche
à sa face au oui on est mieux dans un
pigeonnier golfeuses sa musique tu as
dit et ce qu'il ya bien aussi chez avis
le le pigeon pour les mineurs c'est
quelque chose de doux de céleste qui
contraste avec la mine et sa dureté
les femmes sont un peu jalouse de
l'amitié que les hommes portent à leurs
pigeons l'oncle henry aussi est
colombophile valembois le retraité se
passionne aussi pour l'exigence
l'uniformité du corps on se répercute
jusque dans les loisirs
tous les samedis il y allant logement
edouard flahaut apporte dans un panier
ces champions ses favoris ceux qui vont
participer à la course de pigeons
voyageurs
demain matin
les colombophiles du quartier se
réunissent au cercle le ramier du mines
là chaque pigeon voyageur est dûment
enregistrés mise en loge pour être
expédiées ensuite dans le sud de la
france
il sera lâché demain matin à 5 heures la
colombophilie
c'est une occasion d'une part de se
retrouver d'autre part de voyager en
imagination la télévision les flahaut
ont la télévision
les voisins ont la télévision l'oncle
henry à la télévision les delmotte ont
la télévision toute la rue à la
télévision
dix heures du soir la deuxième équipe
termine le travail
moritz flahaut remonte à la surface
cosma la hausse
mais ont tous
et
[Musique]
il est en avance je commence à se dire
le dimanche est le seul jour de repos
pour les mineurs cosma et buzz j'en
profite pour parler un peu l'avenir des
enfants et leurs grosses aussi la pluie
devoir de mes gars sont en dépendre et
si ça continue comme ça je serais
content d'eux serait fier j'en suis déjà
mais je voudrais tu m'aimes pas qu'il
soit mineur qui parce qu'ils fassent
n'importe quel métier mais jamais mis
naître et le chien commence à voir
maintenant du bien il te roule très bien
et voudrait continuer ses études
d'instituteur alors ce serait très
content je ne pourrais pas l'halloween
parce qu'elle met une métier de mineur
comme en ce moment il est très dur
beaucoup d'occidentaux lycos et pas
beaucoup de sécurité alors sur une bonne
heure de continuer pour acheter du tueur
serait très heureux oui c'est dur le
métier de mineur
le grand père flahaut est mort il ya
trois ans il y causer à 100% il n'a
laissé à ses enfants qu'une seule chose
ces pigeons il passe de père en fils
comme un dépôt familiale
l'arrivée des pigeons le dimanche matin
suscite une attente patients les rieurs
de tout le quartier de la gare est allé
là-bas bourse en dérapant mauvais côté
bondi en est fière ah oui on voit bien
les tribunaux dans l'aria l'enfermement
telle soif on le sait bien
[Musique]
oh
ce jour là maurice flahaut lui va
retrouver sa fiancée pierrette beaudoin
[Musique]
hahaha
m
[Musique]
ainsi chaque dimanche grâce aux pigeons
tout le quartier se trouvent réunies et
échappent pour quelques heures à la loi
exigeante de l'ami
[Musique]